alors dès lors à l'élite au toc toc toc
d'attac
bon bah on sait que c'est benali
mont-sainte-anne château datant du temps
toc toc toc
et là c'est anne holmes qui cette année
là je chantais
[Applaudissements]
l'essai
à
mejdina cette marine et le check in est
mariné et j'ai pas compris la danse
quand on fait comme ça bah c'est pas je
voulais faire un truc un peu comme ça
sur ma vie on dirait qu'on dirait que
vous essuyez le sol allez benhaim très
bien en tout cas pas mal de tharsis
merci beaucoup c'est pas là c'est pas
ouf
attention deux heures dr leslie je suis
qui laisse les rênes du port
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il ya quoi il ya un cours de modern jazz
et la soul
c'est la seule note comme jacques chirac
elle monte id pantalon ici au col roulé
à maintenir cette bonne l'état hôte nous
faire classer au local rue masson ptr
tendance et ses pertes en est l'autre la
karl lagerfeld a assez bon là l'autre
yeux et je lui dis là dans la fois sur
la tête de ma mère l'a fait deux
t-shirts en v elle sera pour eux jean
paul gaultier cela allait
toc toc toc suivant un coq et déjà la
voix c'est quelqu'un de celle où aller
refaites le toc toc et la basse et
justine juste une photo de toi juste une
tente
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allo
vous avez reçu du courrier aujourd'hui
non pourquoi
non mes parts ariary toc
ouais le mec c'est quoi ce dépressif la
t25 au toc toc toc intac les jeunes
viège jeune des filles geneviève je te
bouscule
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vais jouer ma vie
oui
voilà je suis du coin allez merci parti
et ça vous va bien la veste vous avez
c'est vrai mabille ben non non c'est
quand même ça allait aller
il est pas là bas il faut dire toc toc
toc toc
bon allez rentrer à cidre ont ils tous
comme ça moi c'est vous codotussyl 4 a
fait froid hier il a attrapé un coup de
soleil en transformant un numéro d'une
pharmacie je vais commander les choses
qu'on veuille régler leur plein format
s'il a tout de suite des cas c'est aussi
savoir si les gens vous connaissent
d'accord moi si je suis dit allez y voir
si fond d'une petite valérie quand même
et voir s'ils font des promos à la
gauche casher ou halal
allez bon set up tacoma toc toc toc et
ont même eu envie d'ouvrir on n'a pas
les wikis et l'a aidé mon ennemi est mon
contrôle
[Applaudissements]
chanter là a capella la chanson qui vous
avez dit alors elle me contrôle rythme
mais pas si elle me frôlent aux non je
ne réponds répondrait pour plus de toit
pour la faune à coire ce mois tient bon
bilan sur la dance à merde
merci à vous merci tu vas tu appris un
truc à aujourd'hui c'est vrai il alla la
foudre pour né pas on n'est pas prêts là
on n'est pas prêt c'est qui toc toc toc
toc toc toc
jean-michel non senzo juste tombés comme
abonnez vous laissez vos placements je
laissais la fin je regardais pas facile
à les proches à toc toc toc
quentin 40 a souri
[Applaudissements]
et comme il est c'est le seul qui est à
faux savaient qu'ils repèrent les
spectateurs c'est celle à alaric pauvre
chose
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous
hamon
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon histoire c'est pas c'est fait
l'audi a2 les toc toc toc toc
on sait ce qu'on a reconnu un haut c'est
hélas hélas elle a les yeux bleus
manille
[Applaudissements]
chassez belinda qu'est ce que j'ai dit
mais ça non marina oui j'ai fait un
moment en tout cas c'est faux oui c'est
vrai vous êtes venu pourquoi suis venu
parce que c'est la grande brasserie que
j'aime ça non c'est moi comme ça ça va
ou tenait un bar à chicha examinons une
bonne alors il en reste avec un toc toc
je suis le dernier ce jean-michel senzo
attendait à dokki enzo qui pour
l'instant vous restez là bas west ham en
rester là bas pour l'instant
qu'est ce que vous voulez toc toc toc ce
que vous voulez c'est enzo jean-michel
aux attentes de minutes les chéris
voulait tenter de gagner juste comme ça
parce que faire un truc je reviens dans
deux minutes les chéris si vous voulez
tenter de gagner un séjour de rêve d'une
semaine en république dominicaine cet
homme
[Applaudissements]
si vous voulez tenter de gagner un
séjour devrait être d'une semaine en
république dominicaine peso au calme
nous envoyer tes pmp par sms ou 7 38 38
ou bien vous appelez le 39 80 voire 27
quelle bande de 27 39 80 c'est pas du
tout ça un variable mais elle même une
miss march sa maman chérie
ils ne disent que des conneries dans les
grandes écoles alors qu'est ce que tu
veux toc toc toc
jean-michel normand attends attends je
vais te parler de minutes on a parti à
thoune et on la plainte est en train de
me [ __ ] là c'est consommer qu'est ce
que tu avais dit de commencer qu'à merdy
obsession est couché tard yens soit 80
watts envoyé un texto à 4 heures du
matin pour dire tu pouvais pas être que
je me couche à quoi je te dire pourquoi
chaque 4 heures du matin j'ai travaillé
jamais rendez vous en rendez votre
boulot à midi exact non c'est vrai
[Rires]
vacant venir ici mais disons que tu
pourrais pas que là aujourd'hui
non j'ai demandé si éventuellement je
pouvais ne pas être là j'ai pas dis je
ne pouvais pas non mais de façon
personne ne répondra je suis là à merde
et donc mais parce que j'avais un truc
privé ce soir insight une taille de ce
soir une date ou une belle linda part si
non ils ne rient pas pour une bête une
date c'est qu'une jeune fille je connais
ça oui je ne crois pas à grand chose
quoi tu voulais me le dire dans
l'oreille parce que je suis discret
quand il pleuvait toujours pas j'ai
besoin de savoir torchant bon tu vas
faire ton talent tape taupe
ouais je te dire après de quoi pas
pourquoi je ne pouvais pas obtenir après
il faut tenir à toi oui toi c'est que tu
vas me le dire moi je veux dire aux gens
vas-y tu le feras après la pub sous
tutelle
[Applaudissements]